[音楽]
こんにちは
ドクター
始めたこの動画を見ている生徒の皆さんは
エナジードリームというものをご存知
だろうかはいエナジードリンクそうだ
エナジードリンクそもそもどういうものか
と言いますとなんかあの
どうなってしまうどうなんでしょう
エナジードリンクってだからよく聞くのは
なんかそんなに良くないみたいな僕の
知り合いの人は力の前借りだって言ってた
んですけどもまあなんか一時的に力が出る
というか眠い時とか疲れてる時とかに
カフェインになったりアルギニンとか高齢
人参とかちょっと若いよくわかんないです
けどそういうちょっとこうなんかねあの
ちょっとこれは違いますけどドーピング
ってわけじゃないですけども力がみなぎっ
て一時的に頑張れるパワーが出るそんな
恐ろしいドリンクがエナジードリンクと
いうものなんですけども私ドクターはじめ
もよく眠い時に編集とか疲れてるけどどう
しても頑張んなきゃいけない時とかにこう
結構飲んじゃうんですけども日本
よしこの世界にはエナジードリンクこんな
にありました
[音楽]
滑るのに2ヶ月かかった
世界中からエナジードリンクを取り寄せる
のに2ヶ月かかりました
ネットで訳の分からんサイトも行きました
スタッフそうでで今なんとか手に入る世界
のエナジードリンク全種類集めましたそれ
だけで高評価お願いしますただドクター
始めこんなところで終わる男ではない皆
さんもうお気づきでしょう今日はこの
世界中にあるエナジードリンクを全て一つ
にまとめて果たして何味になるのかそして
効果はあるのかどうか実験していきたいと
正直僕カフェイン中毒で
危ないっすよ本当にこれエナジードリンク
飲みすぎて本当になんか歩道が心臓の
バクバクが止まんなくなって結構普通に
なかったことありますけどもいろんな
成分がここにありますと全部混ぜると
味そして効果一体どうなってしまうのか
実験してみたいと思いますではいこう
はいというわけで早速混ぜていこう
マグラムで新たに導入したみてくれこれ
透明な水槽をこれを使えば全部混ぜている
時の色の変化の様子とかをしっかり見れる
のでかなり色覚的にも楽しめると思います
ではマジでいきましょうまずはどうしよう
でも有名どころから来てやっぱこういう
感じですよねレッドブルもう全国の
コンビニにも売ってますレッドブル非常に
お世話になってますレッドベル飲みやす
いっていうのがねかなり目標が高いんです
よねいただきます
[音楽]
一応全部飲むんで一応ここには
ジェットニック全部飲ませていただくので
少量で飲んでいきたいと思います
飛んだらごめんいや美味しいですね
ちょっとなんかリンゴっぽいというか
とても飲みやすいです脱出します
レッドブルブルーエディション
[音楽]
ハワイアンいやレッドブルまで味がいい
なあこれは透明なんだ色が浄化された
レッドバロン家のエディション
[音楽]
うわなんかすごい南国の感じがすごいなあ
とやっぱこうのさあナチュートニックって
缶のかっこよさとか結構大事だよまた黄色
だ黄色に逆戻りだレッドホワイト
エディションすごい種類あるな
うわ透明あずっと入ってくる飲みやすどれ
が一番好きかって言われるとやっぱ
ノーマルかなレッドボールシュガーフリー
レッドブレーのお砂糖を少ない版ですね
アジア微妙だと思いますただシュガフリっ
てねやっぱ健康的にはいいんでしょうね
普通にうまいこれで
モンスタースーパーコーラいや赤い
パッケージかっこよモンスターの想像種類
出てるからね
モンスター僕よく飲みます本当に
うわほんとコーラだ
やばいマジで迷彩生えてきたやばいこれ
そしてうまあとでか色の辺がどうなります
でしょうか
うわしっかりコーラだいやおしっこに
うんこがおしっこうんこになっちゃった
これやばい色が一気に変動した結構透明感
触れる感じだったのになんか一瞬でこんな
感じになっちゃった
モンスターの参上これめっちゃ飲んだこと
あるんですけども
すげー効き目ありますマジでミサイル
[音楽]
バキバキですよもう
すげえほんと黄緑色なんだこれ色
モンスターウルトラレッドマジ赤いやんけ
表現しづらいなさくらんぼなのがちょっと
よくわかんないけど色がめっちゃ赤い
モンスターホワイトパイナップル
色々
うんたいだ方
モンスターウルトラサンライン
黄色だね
[音楽]
うわすげーフルーティーな
ゼロシュガーなんだこれ
防災のやつにゼロシュガー
ゼロ透明っていうか若干濁ってるくらいの
感じかなモンスターエナジーウルトラ
フェスタ
純正にマンゴー好きだからうまそう
黄色だ黄色が多いな
[音楽]
結構俺の中で一番好きなモンスターの味か
もしれん
モンスターウルトラブルー
すげえ本当にブルーだ
[音楽]
いやすごいね
色がやばい色がやばい色が変動起きてる
これやばいモンスターウルトラを食べろ」
「
スイカっぽくて可愛いなうまそうだけどね
うおおやば
思ったよりスイカですごいな割と好きよ色
がまず毒々しいかき氷のシロップみたいに
色しますけどねこれモンスターウルトラ
バイオレット
スカーレット
芳香剤か何かなのかな
この間好きな人は好きなんだろうなぁ色が
すごいでしょ
邪魔モンスターコーヒーエナジーコーヒー
大丈夫かエナジードリンクって書いてある
からエナジードリンクなんでしょうけど
コーヒーやなこれ
あうまカフェオレみたいで美味しいこれは
色の変動をすごそう
うわやばいやばいやばい
全く広く変わってきた大丈夫科学変化が
起きてるけどなんかこううまくいないです
けど
入れなきゃよかった入れなきゃ良かった敵
の何かが漂っておりますこれ果たしてどう
響くのか間違いなくコーヒーの乳製品が
分離してる感じがありますね最悪です
なんか隠しレッドブルあったんだけどこれ
絶対日本じゃないレッドブルック
グランディング250ちょっとまじ読め
ないですこれは多分日本のじゃないな
すごいなこれ何こんなレッドブルがあった
のか色はかなり黄色です
[音楽]
なんかサイズ的に何だろうコイレッドブル
みたいな感じかないやめっちゃ美味しいな
ちょっと待ってこれやばいなこれもたまに
見ますねお店とかであんまり飲んだこと
ないんだよなこう透明ですね
飲みやすい飲みやすい美味しい
色を何とかしてくれ
マジでコーヒーいらんかったな
ゼログラビティめちゃくちゃ普通に
コンドームあるけどまたカロリーとか
シュガーが少なめなんでしょうかさっき
より透明なんでいただきます
なんか水っぽくて飲みやすいな
[音楽]
スリープショット
眠くなっちゃうのかなこれ
睡眠の質を向上これエナジードリンク判定
なのかなまあでも機能性表示食品って書い
てあるんで一応エナジードリンク判定です
ね若干黄色味がかかってます
なんかフルーティー美味しいもうこれ
目が覚めるのが眠くなるのかわかんなく
なってきたのさあやってきました
ゾーン行きましょうかゾーン
[音楽]
泡立ってきてんだけど
ゾーンユートピアユートピアもうっぽい味
がして美味しいの色がゾンビープダイ
めっちゃパッケージかっこいいなこれ
あーうまい
ゾーングラフィティホリックパッケージが
めっちゃ可愛いなマジで
行く
ゾンビジブルースタイプ
インビジティ
コールド3
寝ちゃうのひんやりしてるんかな
[音楽]
うわすごいめっちゃミント効いてるこれ
さあこれで象も終わりましたね
X6エナジーよしきさん
YOSHIKIさんが出せるエナジー
ドリンクだかっこいい
あーこれきくなー
結構外しておりますわこれ
うわーいこれ前にかけてハワイのやつとか
じゃないんでしょうね色的にはだいぶ
ハワイアンブルっぽいですけどメタルいき
ます
ごめんなさい感じに忘れてました
ロビー
皆さん
心臓がバクバクしてきましたちょっとあの
カフェインの取りすぎかもしれませんまず
大丈夫なんですけどまた皆さん絶対真似し
ないようにお願いしますカフェインの摂り
すぎは本当に危険なのでちょっと量少なく
いきますねそろそろ危ない気がしてきまし
た
スパークリングそんなユンケラあるんだ
よカロリー
[音楽]
絆創膏みたいな味がします
これ
[音楽]
馬ここに来て一番やばい色に来たよこれ
もう
え蛍光塗料入ってんのエナジーボンド
やばい
意味わからんなんでございます
格闘技
みんなジュニアかしこみ申し立てていたり
ソフトにマイヤー何これ
ペペロンチーノ
ミラクルエナジップ
剤かないい
[音楽]
意味でいい意味でまずい
阿波踊り専用です
かなり恐怖症的
アースラここな
ゴジラエナジー
ゴジラエナジー2
[音楽]
デーモンえ待って待って待ってやばい色は
大丈夫これ真っ黒だけど
[音楽]
衝撃的な色だなこれやばいここに来て
明らかに色が侵食されてってるぞこれ
エナジージム出発
リアルゴールド
ゴールデンペプシニフレッシュショット
岩にドッペシの味するミラクルボディV
ミラクル
元気一発1発じゃ済まないガスンゴールド
ガツンあすエナジーよーインフィニティ
アルギニVアルギー超メガパッチ
うがい薬
湘南ゴールドエナジー湘南美容外科
クリニック
ビタミンCビタミンエナジーウォーカー
しっかりお酒場ブーストエナジー
キバリティ
エナジーエナジー
N6エナジーエイリアンエナジーエナジー
ドリンエナジーエナジー
海外の細かいやつ色々
[音楽]
ようやくラストの1本です最後は締めの
モンスターエナジー普通のやつ
エナジーはいというわけで皆さんこれで
ようやく世界の全てのエナジードリンクが
この中に集まりました
すごい量ですいややばいちょっと飲み過ぎ
た
ガチでカフェイン取りすぎましたけども
ドクター始めはカフェインにかなり体勢が
あるというなんとか大丈夫ですただこれ
普通の人がこの量を飲むとかなり危険だと
思うので皆さん絶対に真似しないで
くださいカフェインの摂りすぎ本当に気を
つけてくださいよろしくお願いします
ちょっと混ぜてみますちょうど大量の
エナジードリンクが混ざっているので
しっかり混ぜていくと思う
よしよしよしよしよしよしよしよしよし
[音楽]
世界中の命ドリンゴ1つにまとめついに
完成しましたエナジードリンク面
ザワールド
[音楽]
ようやく完成してしまいましたね飛ぶ
みたいな色してますけどもちろんこの
エナジードリンク色は関係ありません世界
のあらゆるエナジードリンクを作った人
たちがこの成分を入れれば元気が出るん
じゃないかこの成分を入れれば決まる
気持ちよくなるんじゃないかいろんな人の
努力おいしさ考え
すべてを1つに混ぜ合わせた史上最強の
エナジートリックがここにあるその
カフェイン量はもう計り知れません
ちょっと人すくいサンプルを取っていこう
と思うサルベージュ
水質調査してるみたいなはい取れました
こんな感じですねはい
[音楽]
味だ果たしてどういう味にたどり着いて
いるのか早速飲んでみますいただきます
[音楽]
研究途中のレッドブルこれまず結構マジで
まとめてる表現の気がするないや皆さん
これ多分レッドブルの味が決まってない時
のこう研究中どうしたらレッドブルが
美味しくなるかっていう研究してる途中の
流れレッドブルの味になってる気がします
その
美味しくないです
[音楽]
今日もいい研究だったなけど
この量のカフェインは一人じゃ取れないな
うーん
みんな
[拍手]